- Social media is like a slot machine,
pull the lever and you
may hit the jackpot,
or you may get zilch,
which is usually what happens.
But with me, you always
win big 'cause I'm amazing.
This is What I'm Liking.
(upbeat music)
(audience applauding)
Educators all over the
country had to get crafty
the moment schools closed their doors
and parents cried.
Two teachers here in
Citrus Heights, California,
didn't just go viral,
this husband and wife pair
now stream a full
fledged production online
to keep their school's beloved
Friday Sing Show alive.
Oh, they're so cute.
Not only do they sing,
they do puppet shows,
guide kids through crafts
and pack in educational info between.
I'm telling you, Mr. Fred Rogers
would be so proud of them.
Let's get this cute couple
on the line right now.
(audience applauding)
Hi Joshua and Jennifer.
Oh, my God! I love y'all.
So how did you come up with this, Joshua?
- Well, my wife and I
have been teaching here
at Orchard Elementary for many years
and she teaches third grade
and I teach fourth grade
and every Friday for the
past 20 years or more,
we've been hosting a live
assembly at our school
on Friday mornings for all of our students
and we sing there and gather together.
But when the schools closed,
of course we weren't
able to meet in person.
So we decided to take
the show to the internet.
And so even now that we're back at school,
it's something that we
find really important
and we want to continue
to share that with,
not just our Orchard community,
but our entire neighborhood and beyond.
(audience applauding)
- Yeah!
Well, Jennifer, this started small,
but it's become quite a
big production, right?
- It sure did start small.
We started out in our
garage, like he said,
and recruited our own two children
to help us film using just
our smartphones at first.
We, over time, you know,
made a lot of mistakes
and had a lot of laughs
through that process
and decided to just keep creating.
We wanted to
add books and puppets
and we design all our own
sets and costumes, puppets,
and just have so much fun.
It's been a lot of our weekend
time creating and rehearsing,
and it's just brought
our family so much joy
and the connections we've
made with the community,
you know, really keep us going.
And we're actually working
on our new series right now.
We have a three-part series
on friendship coming out very soon
and we are just super
excited to get it out
and to share it and-
- Ah!
(audience applauding)
Well, thank you guys so much.
This is such a beautiful
thing you're doing
for not only your community,
but the larger community now online.
I'm liking your posts
right now, all right.
(Jennifer laughing)
- [Joshua] Yes!
- All right, that's not all.
Our season long partner, Pilot Pen,
the go-to pen of the
Kelly Clarkson Show likes
to celebrate those who create
fearlessly, just like you.
So they'll be using their
Frixion erasable pen
to write you a check
for a thousand dollars.
How's that sound?
(audience cheering)
(Kelly laughing)
- Thank you-
- [Kelly] You can get real
crafty with that kind of money.
I'm just saying.